actually you're at a bar catching up
with a friend you haven't seen in months
hey hey the bartender brings you your
drinks and right before you take a sip
the two of you touch glasses and say
cheers Cheers
why does this happen do either of you
know where this comes from yes actually
if you know it don't say it
why don't what you just asked me if I
know so what do you think it is it's a
longer okay you're right about that but
weird is saying cheers come from the TV
show the word cheers comes from the old
French word for face share share we
should just yell face cheer evolved over
time they mean mood or expression and
later went on to mean a good mood but
the exact timing of the origin of the
word cheers as a toast is debated think
I've cracked the glass of it according
to merriam-webster the first use of the
word cheers of the toast was in 1930
however oxford english dictionary
contends that the phrase Cheers came
into use earlier during World War 1
World War one I thought it would be
older I'm thinking like kings
yeah historians speculate that the
origin of the contemporary toast was the
Greek practice of pouring out some of
one's drink to honor the gods pour one
out pour one oh what a mess yeah don't
do that in my house boys like the gods
would like drink the floor drink pouring
out for Zeus like Santa like leaving
cookies out for him yeah can you imagine
if you had to throw cookies and milk on
the floor for Santa
there goes Santa legend has it that the
original purpose of the glass clinking
was to keep away evil spirits including
the evil spirits thought to be
responsible for making people drunk oh
so if you cheers you won't be drunk
that's so they're like why am I getting
like stupid all the time yeah let's
clink our glasses they hate high-pitched
noises author Douglas B Smith suggests
that people clink their glasses together
prior to drinking because in the past
people would attempt to murder their
enemies by poisoning their drink they
would Cheers
and then someone my dream could go in
your drink and yours we could go in my
drink to make sure we weren't poisoning
each other that's what my yes called it
I mean it happens in Game of Thrones
when they like pour each other drinks
and they're like they like don't drink
until after yeah yeah it happened like
it's a weird social game no one is safe
the word toast itself has a strange
backstory stemming from the practice of
dropping a piece of charge or spiced
toast in wine to make the drink taste
better cheers the cheers change the
toast you just drop it in attention a
toast
yeah it tastes like Fritos in the 1700s
the word toast evolved to also mean the
person being honored by the toast
leading to the phrase toast of the town
Oh first century CE e poet Marshall
detailed the Roman practice of having
guests drink as many glasses of wine as
there were letters in their hosts
mistress named Stephanie was the most
popular girl and I was just known as
shut up to his party's word we're Brad
guy you went down at the P he's done
didn't
you have to worry about the poison when
you're just choking on toast the whole
time and over the years the custom
evolved and people no longer drink
entire glasses during a toast instead
taking a small sip of their drinks or
even just making eye contact with a
person being tested was enough it's like
a greeting cheers mate like cheers
Cheers some people use it as their sign
off on their emails no Mike this guy
cheers Cheers Jonathan hey if you
couldn't get this back to me by the end
of today that would be really great
Cheers
[Music]